Earth has a new ship and you're going to
love it
welcome to style Trek your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so last week's video was a fan fiction
theory of how I thought they were going
to basically save the crew of Destiny
and in that video I created a new ship
the BC 306 Horizon and I thought it
would be fun to theorize on what that
ship would look like what technology
would be available how many people it
would be able to carry how far it would
be able to go now we already know it has
a wormhole drive so pretty damn far but
how is it powered well I thought about
it I've designed it and I hope you enjoy
this the BC 306 Horizon The
Intergalactic Battleship will be huge by
Earth standards
it will be 450 meters long
195 meters wide and will have a crew of
up to 400 people now just to put that
into perspective the deadless is half
the size only being able to hold 200
people and it doesn't have a wormhole
Drive some key features of the bc306
Horizon are the additions of a new power
source that being an array of up to 5
zpm modules much like how Atlantis the
city ship is powered because of this
array and the size of the ship is
actually able to travel a lot further
than what Atlantis is
being a little bit smaller than what
Atlantis is probably about 2.9 times
smaller the bc306 can travel between
galaxies much much quicker the way it
does that will be Through the Wormhole
drive a new Drive adapted from lantian
technology developed by McKay and Carter
essentially how this will work is it
will create a wormhole in front of the
ship
this will then connect two points in
space that the ship can travel through
the ship has Asgard Shields which means
that whoever's Going Through the
Wormhole doesn't need to be
dematerialized because they are
protected so they're not going to be
subject to the vacuum within the
Wormhole this means that the ship can
safely pass through the wormhole on one
side and exit on the other side in a
different point in space entirely very
similar to how a Stargate works the
Wormhole Drive is located on the rear of
the ship and it is actually pretty big
which makes a lot of sense because it
has to generate a wormhole large enough
to Encompass the entire ship the power
source for how this is possible is
located at the front of the ship in the
middle in a zpm array now I'm assuming
at some point over the last 10 years
they found a way to recharge zpms and
this is how it is possible for them to
have more than one zpm active at a time
now as this is a theoretical ship I'm
going to add some limited patients to it
the first limitation that I'm going to
give to it is that it cannot just
instantly travel between one end of the
universe to the other it has to do a
kind of jump
which is why in my fan Theory it's going
to take them three months to get from
Earth to where the destiny is it can go
pretty far but it can't go that far in
an instant which is why they need five
zpms it's going to take a lot of power
to do the jumps required now whilst the
Wormhole Drive is incredibly powerful it
is not the same Wormhole drive from
Atlantis it is adapted technology made
by the greatest Minds on Earth Rodney
McKay and Sam Carter they haven't quite
figured out these limitations yet but I
think it adds to the story and it makes
it a little bit more realistic so
essentially for them to get from where
Earth is located in the universe to
where Destiny is located in the universe
they will have to do a series of jumps
each jump will require there to be a
cooldown much like the FTL drive on
Destiny they can't just jump jump jump
it's going to require a cooldown which
is why it's going to take three months
now in terms of how the ship is designed
and how it looks it's an Earthship it's
going to look very very human think
about how the deadlift looked it's gray
it's flat it has a very Earth human-like
quality to it
this is going to be a very similar ship
design with one caveat the Wormhole
Drive is going to be a big
glowing ball of blue energy located at
the rear of the ship this is going to
set apart all of the other Earth ships
that we've seen before this is going to
be very much One of a Kind ship now it
is classed as a battleship much like the
Daedalus was has an arrangement of
weapons thanks to the Asgard core the
ship now has much more advanced Shields
energy-based weapons and of course it
will have an arrangement of Towery based
weapons rear as well now unlike the
deadless it actually holds a lot more
fighter jets
the Daedalus will hold anywhere between
8 and 16 whereas this can hold anywhere
up from 50 to 100 it has a dedicated
hanger Bay and that is why it is called
a battleship because it is more than
capable of destroying anything that it
comes into contact with but on those
small fights it's going to be able to
send out a large arrangement of Fighters
now one addition to this ship is the
fact that it also has cloaking
technology now this wasn't possible
before with the exception of the Odyssey
when Daniel Jackson has a prior made it
cloak
this is now a dedicated module that can
actually turn the ship invisible however
this does create some unfortunate side
effects
it is using the same technology as the
shields much like what they did with
Atlantis City ship where they use the
shields to turn the the city invisible
they're using the same sort of
Technology here which means when the
cloak is active the ship is actually
more vulnerable
so it's actually used pretty sparingly
mainly for more covert operations it's
also equipped with the Asgard beaming
technology a long range transmitter
which can actually travel between
galaxies another bit of tech that would
have been created by McKay and Carter
I love those guys and of course it has
Transportation Rings although as it is
an Intergalactic Battleship those rings
are very rarely used because well the
Rings aren't in other galaxies as far as
we know now in terms of the power output
for this ship
it is able to hold as I mentioned before
up to five zpms exactly how Atlantis is
arranged now at full power Atlantis is
completely Unstoppable you cannot
penetrate the shields the weapons from
Atlantis will absolutely annihilate
anything that comes into contact and
with those five zpms in place Atlantis
is able to travel between galaxies using
the Wormhole drive and that's exactly
why they have them with those five zpms
on a much smaller ship they're able to
travel a lot far farther in a lot
shorter time with the caveats that I've
already mentioned of course
this is the ship that I would love to
see in a reboot of Stargate this is how
I want them to have developed the
technology I want them to travel further
I want them to go to different galaxies
I want them to get lost I want them to
have Adventures using this ship because
this is the most powerful ship that
Atari would have ever gotten but what I
want to know is what you think would you
like to see this ship use balotari or do
you have any other ideas of how you
imagine the V3 kills 306 to be after
watching my previous video
let me know in the comment section down
below I would be very interested to find
out what you think if you are new to the
channel make sure you hit like And
subscribe and whilst you're down there
consider becoming a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button down below
thank you so much for watching and I
will see you next week
[Music]